LILIANA YU: Google
Cloud Shell provides you
with command line access
to your cloud resources
directly from your browser.
You can easily manage your
projects and resources
without having to install the
Google Cloud SDK or other tools
on your system.
With Cloud Shell, the Cloud
SDK gcloud command line tool
and other utilities, we are
always available, up-to-date,
and fully authenticated
when you need them.
Cloud Shell provides
command line access
to a virtual machine
instance in a terminal window
that opens in the web console.
In this hands-on
lab, you will learn
how to connect to
computer resources
posted on Google Cloud
Platform via the web.
You will learn how to use
Cloud Shell and gcloud command.
We encourage students to
type the commands themselves,
to help encourage learning
at the core concepts.
Many labs will include
a code block that
contains the required commands.
You can easily copy
and paste the commands
from the code block into
the appropriate places
during the lab.
When you're done
with this lab, you
will know how to launch Cloud
Shell and run gcloud commands.
All you need to
work on this lab is
familiarity with standard
Linux text editors,
such as Vim, eMax, or Nano.
And account, project,
and associated resources
are provided to
you on Quick Labs.
This self-paced lab is part
of the Quick Labs quest GCP
essentials.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
Next, you will provision
services with Cloud Launcher.
[MUSIC PLAYING]